et je pense que la silence peut-être
brisée quand il y a des succès qui sont
concrétisés que l'Ukraine peut annoncer
peut-être que ils sont aussi le besoin
d'annoncer des succès puisque il y avait
beaucoup de nouvelles un peu un peu
mixte venant de source pas très fiable
sur comment la contrefontive valait
alors il s'agit de deux villages dans la
région de thononet mais il y a juste
confins de la région de zapporisa donc à
la toute ouest extrémité de la région de
thônette platane et Nesquik Schneck qui
ont été libérés selon les paroles
militaires ukrainien par deux brigades
différentes de l'armée ukrainienne même
si les villages sont à proximité l'un
d'autres le porte-parole a donné des
détails sur la prise de données il a dit
que l'armée avait eu des difficultés
pour rentrer dans le village parce que
les forces russes étaient au centre
culturel du village et aussi dans un
école est tirée depuis ses bâtiments
mais que les Ukrainiens finalement ont
fait
c'est peut-être nous adapté pour ce
début de contrefensif les potes parole
ukrainiens ont tout de même fait aussi
de difficultés à d'autres endroits sur
la ligne de front ils ont dit notamment
que l'armée était attaquée par les
forces russes à côté de marinka qui est
juste à l'ouest de Donald